i mean how do you sleep the night before
a super bowl are you sleeping
no sleep i haven't slept in 30 years
you know the reason why i don't sleep is
because i'm visualizing
what's going to happen the next day i'm
playing the game already in my head
because
the night before uh the actual game we
put in like the first 15
plays so i'm going down that list
and i'm looking at my opportunities
where i'm uh you know i'm gonna be able
to uh
uh be well just impact the game yeah
so i play this game over and over
the night before the day of the game
or it's a long day because the super
bowl is not until late that evening
and i can't eat because i'm so nervous i
got butterflies
anything that goes in my stomach is
gonna come back
up so it's a long day for me so i always
go over to the stadium
on the first bus so i go over to the
stadium
uh super bowl super bowl uh 23
uh i think it's against the cincinnati
bengals
i get to the stadium i put my uniform on
and i fall asleep
on the table hey because i'm tired
i'm tired i've been up all night and i
have played this game over and over my
head my teammates are walking by and
they're saying man
what's that with jerry this is a simple
bowl and he's sleeping
yeah man i had prepared the right way
and i was ready to go
and i went out and i was able to do some
great things on the football field and i
also that was my
uh that was my uh most valuable player
uh football super bowl oh yeah so you
took a nap
and then woke up and got the mvp in the
super bowl
it was time to go to work man
yeah dude